[Music]
this is star talks sports edition I'm
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist got with me my
co-host Gary Gary Reilly I'm good thank
you all right all right when when he's
not otherwise announcing soccer he is
with us here on Star Talk former Soccer
Pro always good to have you there Gary
and of course Chuck Nice Jack hey former
nothing
[Music]
every time I call you you're there all
right there you go today's today's for
today's topic we're thinking about human
longevity and is it
a good thing what does it mean to live
to 200 if you have a 200 year old body
for example we're going to get to the
bottom of that and with the obvious
connections to how long can someone be
at the top of their game athletically
just as an example and so Gary what have
you put together for today's show let's
meet our first guest Dr Peter attia
Stanford University School of Medicine
trained at Johns Hopkins in general
surgery for five years founder of early
medical practice that applies medicine
3.0 which we will be getting into
shortly host of the podcast the drive
author of outlive the science of
longevity and you'll love this one once
planned to take a PhD in aerospace
engineering so uh but he didn't but he
did we'll ask him he may have done it
quietly okay yeah
all right now not gonna the whole show
I'm gonna have to get on his case for
not getting the PHD but he might have it
he may have it tucked up his sleeve
somewhere and he's not wearing it you're
kidding me this he's a he's a veritable
plus de Leon and you're talking about
Aerospace
live forever
good right very good point and we ought
to remember who Ponce de Leon is in your
reference there but yes he's a Spanish
explorer who went searching for the
Fountain of Youth right and the reason
why I know that because I wrote a book
report on him when I was in fifth grade
and so you have it there you go
so Peter welcome to StarTalk thanks for
having me guys so Peter uh is our human
body
really built or have the capacity to
last longer than we are right now and I
actually I you know it's a really
obvious question and it's not clear how
obvious the answer will be because I I
know we are living twice as long as we
work on average twice as long as we were
150 years ago or so and we're living
longer than at least in heartbeats than
any other mammals on Earth so we're
doing something right and you're
thinking we could just keep at this
yeah I mean I I do think there is a
limit to human lifespan
um where we are in relation to that
limit I I don't think anybody knows and
I I certainly don't think it's
significantly longer than where we are
uh in other words I you know when people
talk about oh we're all going to live to
200 or kids born today are going to you
know be effectively Immortal I just have
a very hard time believing that and of
course there's nothing that's black
you're trying to sell a book called
Longevity could you say nicer things
foreign
evity is two pieces to it and you kind
of alluded to this at the outset right
but one of them is the lifespan piece
and that's the easier one for people to
think about because it's binary uh
you're either alive or you're dead
you're respiring or you're not but an
equally important part of this if not I
think more important is the health span
piece and that that part's analog and I
think that's the part that is you know
much more subject to the individual's
views on the quality of their own life
and two people can have a very different
set of metrics for what constitutes
quality of life there I think what's
abundantly clear is that while our
length of life has indeed doubled as you
stated Neil from about 40 to 80 since
it's not clear that that has come with a
doubling in the quality of life so we've
basically traded one set of problems for
another we've we've effectively solved
the problem for the most part of acute
death largely brought on by infectious
diseases and Trauma and we've shifted
that over to Chronic death uh for which
we don't actually have a great solution
at this time
oh okay so just to be clear about
language here so acute death would be
you're live one minute and you drop dead
the next and and and chronic death is
you there's some long disease that puts
you in the hospital for some time and
then you die is that what you mean by
those two different yeah I mean so when
you think of chronic diseases you think
of what I kind of talk about as the Four
Horsemen of disease the atherosclerotic
diseases so heart disease stroke cancer
neurodegenerative disease such as
Alzheimer's and Parkinson's and then of
course the whole cluster of metabolic
diseases around type 2 diabetes such as
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease and
insulin resistance etc those things
percolate for years uh and in some cases
decades and even when someone dies
suddenly for example a person drops dead
of a heart attack that process was
brewing inside their coronary arteries
for decades
you know but didn't isn't it true that
people didn't get a chance to experience
chronic death uh as short as maybe a
hundred years ago and that's because
often uh external uh of forces
intervened and and affected life you're
talking about pandemics something we
just went through you're talking about
all kinds of infectious diseases and uh
and then also uh something as simple as
breaking a hip or an arm you die of an
infection like you know crap that we'd
take for granted now killed everybody
back in the day that's exactly I think
that's what he just said yeah Chuck but
the point is but but to Chuck's point
it's not that these are new problems
that you cite these chronic diseases
it's that we didn't live long enough to
even we never got to show up on well I
would say I would say there's there's
two things there so everything you said
Is Right Chuck that we we basically you
know didn't earn the right to die of
chronic diseases back then because we
didn't live long enough on average to
have them however I think there's plenty
of evidence that our current environment
while remarkable in many ways right
modernity has brought great things with
it it's come at a cost and the cost has
been
we eat too much we don't exercise enough
we don't sleep enough we're under too
much chronic stress and those things I
would argue are also exacerbating the
problem so we have this ability to live
longer and be more exposed to these
things that therefore render us more
susceptible to chronic disease doctor
are you suggesting that current Medical
Science has been looking for the answers
in the wrong places like treating
symptoms and conditions rather than
looking at the early identification and
therefore predict prediction and
prevention so yes is this effect you're
calling medicine 3.0 because that's
that's what I'm calling medicine 2.0 so
medicine 2.0 was a really successful
playbook for treating the problems that
were killing us basically for all of
human history and and there are
basically two huge things that
catapulted catapulted us from medicine
1.0 which was basically kind of
Witchcraft and you know Voodoo medicine
into medicine 2.0 so so the the first is
sort of you know Francis Bacon coming
along in the late 17th century or mid
17th century effectively coming up with
a new frame of thinking about science
right so we we collectively can sit here
on this podcast today and take for
granted something called the scientific
method right which is that you you know
I don't need to State this to you guys
but you know you you make an observation
right You observe something in the
natural world you make an observation
you formulate a hypothesis you design an
experiment to test that hypothesis you
measure the results of the experiment
against the prediction of the hypothesis
and you correct and we iterate and
iterate and iterate well we you know
people who are in science today take
that for granted there was a day that
didn't that was as foreign to the world
as an airplane was right so that call
that step one step two was more
Technical and it was basically the
development of the light microscope
those two things separated by a couple
hundred years effectively allowed us a
window into a world that then allowed us
to create therapies namely antimicrobial
therapies and vaccines that allowed us
to basically eradicate for the most part
communicable diseases infectious
diseases not in my child but not in my
child
and control my kid you're not going to
mind control my kid I'll tell you right
now you keep your politics to
yourself no no his his vaccines don't
have microchips in them it's a different
vaccine Church oh oh okay I'm sorry okay
yeah the polio vaccine had no microchips
in it yeah so yeah so so that Playbook
worked very well the problem is the the
systems that were required for that
system to work for example the
randomized control trial wow don't work
very well in treating cancer or
preventing cancer or in preventing
cardiovascular disease because of many
factors that we don't have to get into
now but among them the chronicity of
these disease is in the time course and
the complexity of the interventions used
to prevent them you see it's really easy
to do a randomized controlled trial in
humans when the intervention is take
this pill versus take this Placebo that
works pretty well imagine I said listen
guys we're going to do an experiment
where the next 30 Years these people
need to eat exactly this way these
people need to eat exactly this people
this way these people need to exercise
exactly this way and then in 30 years
let's see how things are going I mean
that experiment can't be done for so
many reasons that it's not worth going
into them and therefore we start up
something that is so important for
people to understand and I think we're
saying it like a throwaway which is you
know uh your RCT and RCT really
revolutionized that was kind of like a
medical Revolution because I think what
people forget is that a lot of times no
matter how you get sick your body
sometimes will recover a lot of times
we'll recover so there was a time where
they were just like eat some dirt and
then you would recover and then they'd
be like see dirt is the answer so I mean
maybe you should yes all CT what does
RCT mean randomized control trial and
and I'm glad you brought that up Chuck
because we are throwing that around
without giving it its due course which
is again that's a big part of the
scientific method randomization is
essential to eliminate bias and to
eliminate confounding and to determine
causality so causality is such an
important thing in science and without
those tools it's very difficult to
establish causality and that's why
medicine 1.0 was all about bad humors
right elixirs nonsense I know all about
bad humor
I'm sorry in fact you're occasionally
good for Good Humor I think okay thank
you Neil So Peter so what you're saying
is in modern times since those
experiments you described are not
executable for many reasons including at
some level just the ethics of what it is
to force someone in their life to do
something that you think might give them
cancer but now you want to see if it
actually does so we're left with finding
isolated populations in the world that
might have those habits just as a matter
of their culture their religion or for
their Traditions is it and yeah and of
course as well right well but not by
itself right because it still can't
establish causality so we we still have
this problem of we we have to get away
from the gold standard and instead rely
on a whole bunch of imperfect things and
make inferences based on a lot of
imperfect things so yes we would still
rely on epidemiology let's remember
something the relationship between
cigarettes and lung cancer was never
established using an RCT it was
established using epidemiology but the
epidemiology was so compelling there
that we are very confident in
establishing causality and making bold
claims policy wise and medically about
this we had a huge sample too you got to
remember because yeah
well it's the sample size was less the
issue it's the magnitude of the hazard
ratio and the dose response that
probably played a greater role in other
other words it was the ability so first
of all the hazard ratio was like 10
right this is a log more than the hazard
ratios we see with things like you know
eating this food versus eating bat food
where your hazard ratio is like 1.7 or
something like that and then you had the
dose effect so the more you smoked the
more likely you were so there's this guy
named Austin Bradford Hill who was kind
of The Godfather of this statistical
methods utilized to establish and
understand rcts and he proposed these
nine
um basically checks that you would run
through your epidemiologic observations
and the more those checks you had the
more confident you could be that
causality was in fact underneath this
correlation cool so Dr the phrase people
get sick right are we saying now that's
the wrong way to look at it the person
gets sick and I need to know that person
because it's that person I'm treating so
therefore I have to really have an
intimate knowledge of that person
because they might be presenting the
same symptoms as the person in the bed
next to them but one's bacterial one's
viral so the treatment for both is the
same one of them's not gonna cure one's
not going to get better so we need to
have is that what you're saying we need
to have that specific yeah this is the
next layer this is now how we have to
get to Medicine 3.0 because what you've
highlighted is a very important point
that also gets lost in the the culture
of only the RCT is valuable keep in mind
the RCT takes a whole bunch of people
who are heterogeneous
and it finds the average outcome so it
spits out homogeneous from heterogeneous
and to your point at the end of the day
any physician who's taken care of a
human being will tell you that you can
have exactly the situation you're having
and by the way I'll go one step further
it's not just well this these two are
both sick but it turns out one's viral
and one's bacterial it's like no no
these two people are having the exact
same heart attack or these two people
have the exact same cancer but there
might be different factors about them
that will make one susceptible to a
treatment while the other is not maybe
they're an underlying immune system
genetics and cancer treatment right now
you know so
wow what wait but all right but but
getting back to the theme of this
program you're all right so suppose we
do cure all that at the end of the day
we we
live longer because we're not dying from
those disease but we're still getting
older all right and so is there a
a limit Beyond susceptibility to disease
that you think we will still confront is
this is there another wave of things we
will hit when we all live to 150. oh my
gosh look what we're dying of now all
right uh because we got to live that
long is that is this in our future well
this is actually a pretty interesting
debate within the Aging Community
because what you're really asking and I
think it is the jugular question
is do we take up your medical analogies
the jugular question that question just
slipped my damn throat
that's a dangerous question
damn okay I'm loving I love the extra
vocabulary here okay go on so on so if
independent of disease what is aging now
there are these nine Hallmarks of Aging
that you know obviously play a role in
disease so let's take one of them for
example genomic instability there's no
mystery here that the older we get the
more we accumulate genetic mutations
right well that directly feeds into at
least one of the four horsemen right
cancer is fed by that in fact that's the
sin quanon of cancer right cancer arises
when cells acquire somatic mutations and
those mutations produce a phenotype
meaning they produce uh a cell whose
properties are
two things one it no longer responds to
cell cycle signaling so it will grow in
an unregulated Manner and two it has the
capacity to leave its site of origin so
let me just as a regular person see if I
understood what you just said there
because that was that was nothing
regular about you but please continue
it's like did you did you just say
because this and if I'm wrong I'm wrong
I don't care I'm just telling you what I
heard that cancer basically is already
in you but what happens is you're making
a replica of yourself over the years it
gets to a point where you're replicating
those cells but they no longer uh they
kind of say ah I'm gonna break the rules
I don't care about the rules I'm not
going to generate or regenerate the way
I should so as a matter of fact oh
as a matter of fact forget it I'm gonna
have a party and I'm just I'm gonna
regenerate like crazy and you know and
so basically that's cancer yeah think
about it if you if a person gets colon
cancer like I'll just pick that because
it's the third leading cause of cancer
death that grows out of colon cells that
are in your body and those are cells
that have to reproduce constantly
because you're constantly sloughing off
cells in your colon but the problem is
if one of those cells acquires a set of
mutations that basically makes it death
to the signals that tell them when to
grow and when to stop right and acquires
mutations that allows it to leave the
colon and go somewhere else all of a
sudden it grows and grows and grows
and everybody around is saying hey dude
you got to stop you gotta stop get us up
he's like I don't hear you I don't hear
you I'm just gonna keep growing and oh
by the way I can leave and go to the
liver and take up residence there that's
what's going to kill you look at that
wow but let me go back to Neil's
question right so so so you asked a
question Neil well what if
you somehow figure out a way to cure all
Cancers and what if you somehow figure
out a way to cure heart disease and what
if you somehow figure out a way to not
get Alzheimer's disease will we still
age and I think the answer is yes right
I still think there are enough of these
other processes that are going on where
for example are mitochondria which are
the little you know energy producing
organelles of our cells become less and
less effective and that will for example
mean you are weaker you have less energy
even absent a quote unquote disease so I
don't know truthfully which side of this
debate I come down on right is aging
necessarily an implication of disease or
is there an aged phenotype absent
disease I probably lean more towards
that side of the philosophical debate
though oh now you just made me think of
this what happens they say whatever
doesn't kill you makes you stronger is
it possible that it's just the opposite
that you get a disease that disease
makes you weaker and then later on in
life you're actually weaker because it
just weakened you and now something else
has come to attack you and you know and
that makes you I mean I think there are
examples of both right so the process
you're describing in the first uh part
of that statement is what we call
hormesis right what doesn't kill you
makes you stronger so again to bring it
back to your favorite subject to
vaccination vaccination is a form of
hormesis we introduce a small amount of
the virus sometimes we would disable it
or whatever in the traditional sense
Let's ignore the MRNA vaccine so we
would give you kind of a deactivated or
weakened virus or attenuated in some way
it makes you a little sick right but
your body Rises to that equation to that
to that occasion it develops a huge
memory response to it and the next time
that virus shows up you're ready to
pounce it exercise is probably my
favorite form of hormesis in the short
term exercise does everything wrong to
your body it raises your heart rate it
raises your blood pressure it lowers
your heart rate variability it induces
stress hormones everything about
exercise while you're exercising your
muscles right sure right yeah it tears
down muscle fibers so if you're
exercising for two hours a day that two
hours isn't what's making you healthy
what's making you healthy is the other
22 hours of the day when your body
responds to that adapts to that and gets
stronger as a result of that we got to
take a quick break when we come back
we're going to see what roles sleep
plays in our Health and Longevity and
what else we might have control over
to live the life we hope we want to
leave as we get older on Star Talk
we're back start talk with Dr Peter
attia who is an expert on aging and
Longevity a medical doctor and he's
written a book
and uh Peter tell us the title of that
book the full title outlive the science
and art of longevity I love it I love it
and of course you're the host of the
popular podcast the drive
and so let me just lead off something a
point I wanted to make earlier there are
people who don't fully Embrace or
understand the statistics of disease so
for example if the Press reports cancer
rates are up
relative to 50 years ago
I'm
how often is it that they're up because
people are simply living longer and then
have that susceptibility for having
lived longer so therefore they shouldn't
start wondering what's happening in
their environment that could be giving
them cancer
yeah it it really comes down to how
those things are reported so as you know
there's one way to think about this is
through the lens of incidents in another
way is through the lens of prevalence so
um and then on top of that so I think a
better example Neil might actually be
Alzheimer's disease because that's the
most clearly associated with aging so we
would say that today both the incidence
and prevalence of Alzheimer's disease is
significantly higher than it was say 50
years ago and now the question becomes
what are the confounders there well one
really big confounder is not just that
we're living a bit longer now it's that
we are much better in our diagnostic
acumen so what would have been
Alzheimer's disease 50 years ago was
Mom's a little loopy and it's sort of
you know she's a bit senile whereas now
we have diagnostic tools to make that
distinction more clearly
um that said
in every treatment that I've looked at
especially with respect to Alzheimer's
disease the incidence is indeed
increasing even when adjusted for age so
it does suggest that we are actually
getting a little less healthy
but because medicine is also getting
better we're kind of stretching out
extra years of life albeit at probably a
lower quality so our lifespan and to put
it in the speak of what we discussed in
the last segment our lifespan is
incrementally getting longer while our
health span is eroding at least by my
definition now some people have a
different definition of Health spin that
is more
you know frankly I think not strenuous
enough which says it's the time of life
you are free from disability and disease
I think that's a pretty useless
definition truthfully
um I think we want to be more particular
about cognitive and physical capacity
doctor we're going to jump into the
neurodegenerative process and diseases
because you saw that as one of the four
horsemen of disease in your book
if I do my ab crunches or whatever you
know and or in my planks and I like pump
some iron and I you know run the track
I I still don't live to 150. no so
what's up with that
but it doesn't make a difference because
I look I look I look amazing
are you happy now you feel better for
that yeah you look good on the beach
yeah
but exercise I would argue makes a
bigger difference than any other
intervention we have so there you have
these interventions that like whether it
be you know the right nutrition exercise
sleep Etc but the data would suggest
that exercise has a bigger impact on
your longevity than anything else and
the you know the the two metrics that we
have that are probably most rigorous to
measure that is strength and cardio
respiratory Fitness Peak
cardiorespiratory Fitness something
measured by VO2 max Gary you must have
had a VO2 max back that test done back
in the day uh yeah
he's too old we chiseled that on the
side of the cave
it's really quiet it's a test anybody
could go and do right so you all could
go do this next week
I mean as much as I do know we have
these and you mentioned these guys
before in the in segment one the
mitochondria because there are little
powerhouses
as far as I can see in my Layman's
terminology but do they not diminish
in terms of number and efficiency as we
get older and
exercising as you just Neil just pointed
out you know do my ABS pump my iron run
the track but that doesn't help as much
so there has to be a way to exercise
does indeed improve mitochondrial
efficiency but it has to be the right
kind of exercise so for example if
that's your specific aim you have to do
it correctly so a a silly example would
be if you tell me your objective is to
have bigger biceps it doesn't really
matter if you do all the leg extensions
in the world yeah and similarly if
you're telling me
as you should be that you want to Target
mitochondrial efficiency and I would
argue we should then you have to train
in a way that targets that and the way
to do that is a type of training called
zone two training so zone two training
is aerobic steady state activity that is
right at the threshold of lactate
production at the mitochondria now for
people who don't want to do what I like
to do which is actually measure lactate
production while exercising a very
simple heuristic for doing this
is
assessing your perceived exertion during
exercise and making sure you're at the
following threshold you are able to
speak but you don't want to where where
let's get the vocabulary well I want to
make we got vocabulary here
so what we have lactose which is sort of
no lactate but then we think no no like
lactated acid yeah yeah they're totally
different yeah
so let's help Chuck out here let's help
out Chuck and I think of the lactic acid
buildup in muscles that can work back
against you if you reach that zone and
lactose which is a milk sugar so that's
right that's right yeah so lactate is a
byproduct of anaerobic metabolism which
is just another way of saying when your
muscles are demanding energy at a rate
that can't be met purely through the
much more efficient but slow burning
process of utilizing oxygen what's
called aerobic metabolism you turn to
this other method which has the benefit
of giving you ATP or energy very quickly
but with a nasty side effect which is
it's also starting to accumulate lactate
and if you can't tolerate that lactate
buildup which most of us can't at a high
enough level your exercise becomes
limited now what you want to do is
increase the capacity of your
mitochondria to develop ATP to produce
ATP
at the at the highest work capacity
possible and to do that you have to
train right at that threshold and as I
said you can you can do this in a very
technical way but you can get eighty
percent of the value just by saying look
I'm gonna go you know walk on a steep
incline on the treadmill and I'm going
to titrate that incline and speed until
I'm right at the point where if my wife
comes in and talks to me I can talk with
her a little but I just don't want to if
you can't talk at all you're beyond that
you're actually into too much lactate
production then you're not going to get
that training adaptation and if you're
too far below that if it's actually easy
to have a discussion then you're not
training hard enough so that's a very
specific example where you use exercise
in a very targeted way to train a very
specific adaptation so what what is
it then that there's so much around this
hit training this high intensity
training uh so that uh it's like kind of
like what you say except you do exceed
the threshold but only for short bursts
and then rest recover do it again what's
the difference there a significant
difference um there's nothing wrong with
hit training but it really comes out of
uh a sort of human condition of looking
for the minimum effective dose for
everything so if someone says look I've
only got 30 minutes a week that I'm
willing to exercise how can I make the
best use of it then yeah you're probably
if you're truly going to draw that Line
in the Sand and say I'm only willing to
do 30 minutes a week yeah you're
probably better off doing 10
you know minute short bursts of brutal
Activity three times a week what I'm
saying is let's put that caveat or
constraint rather aside and say what's
actually the best thing to be doing and
the data would suggest probably at least
three if not four hours a week of just
that kind of steady state cardio and
then we have to talk about the strength
training and some of the higher
intensity stuff as well and before you
all say who the hell has time for that I
would argue
if you're in the business of trying to
live longer and live as well as possible
you have to ask yourself the question
what's more important
so Dr when your patients come to you and
you you explain the zone 2 exercise and
the benefits they're in why'd you advise
them to do the VO2 max training as well
what is the what is the Synergy between
the two of them that's so effective
so tell us what VO2 max is sure sure so
VO2 max is this test that measures
literally the maximum amount of oxygen
your muscles can utilize and to do that
you're strapped up to this mask and
you're put into a very stressful
situation usually on a bike or a
treadmill and you are pushed until you
fail
and during that period of time these
sensors so there's an O2 sensor and a
CO2 sensor on the mask it will basically
tell you this is the maximum amount of
oxygen you were able to consume in
liters per minute so it's calculating
something known as the ventilatory rate
of oxygen consumption
and the bigger
ventilatory yeah the V is ventilatory
right so VO2 max is ventilatory rate of
oxygen consumption so it's technically
VO2 it's v.o2 Max
um and so
um the bigger that number the fitter you
are and the longer you live in fact
there is no metric we have that is more
correlated with lifespan than VO2 max
wow
so doctor if I don't live in a 50
million dollar Penthouse apartment and
have a Peloton and have an elevator that
goes that goes up the price of Peloton I
don't think you need to live in that
apartment anymore
nice thanks
exactly exactly what are we missing
Chuck let's get let's get busy so the
thing the thing is I got a bad knee my
hip plays me up stuff's not easy for me
to do this is why I don't live on the
penthouse because the elevator gets
broken and I can't walk all those
flights of stairs so what are we trying
to do because you know what life takes a
bite out of us doesn't allow us to be as
perfectly fit as we once were or we'd
like to be so how are people
working around these sort of impediments
to get to where they need to be
plus I want to hear more about sleep too
with this segments oh yeah for sure that
falls in here somehow yeah so look I
think one has to come up with ways to to
to get the circulatory system moving so
if a person says look I can't
walk on a treadmill or I can't climb
stairs then maybe they can get on a bike
where there's less impact or if that
doesn't work maybe they can be in a pool
or on a rowing machine but unfortunately
this type of activity has to be done and
if injuries are preventing all of that
then those injuries have to be addressed
um you know that's that is an important
part of living longer is being free of
pain yeah um that that factors in very
heavily to my definition of Health span
at least where Freedom From Pain is a
Pursuit yeah and most people do not
follow up on injury most of us have
received some type of injury in life and
then they don't follow up on the rehab
for that injury properly and then I just
recently found out that no injury heals
it's just it just stops hurting until
you until you're 49 years old
you know how that works Chuck okay it
never it did not heal it just stopped
hurting and then all of a sudden one day
you're like why is this hurting again
and uh yeah it's because you didn't do
the rehab you big dummy so truck is
writing a book all the that happens
to you when you turn 50. yeah okay so
it'll be out next year people all right
so
I just had one coach who would say me
the harder you work the harder you have
to rest
and for years no one gave a damn right
but now you have got athletes wandering
around with the wrist ornaments that
will tell their medical team how much
sleep they got the quality of sleep they
had now if it's good enough for elite
athletes it's surely doing something
special so what is the whole secret
behind getting sleep because we've kind
of ignored it for most of our lives
really yeah no one even thought about it
yeah yeah and and look I did till about
10 years ago I was very much of the
mindset that I'll sleep when I'm dead
um but
I think the science is pretty
unequivocal here and and so too if you
just once in a while it's nice when
Evolution makes such an obvious
statement which is why did Evolution not
get rid of this thing that kept us
unconscious a third of Our Lives unable
to hunt for food reproduce fend
ourselves against danger I mean so
there's there's a pretty compelling case
for why we and every other species on
this planet require sleep it's a great
point and I've joked about this where
aliens come to Earth and say what these
humans are semi comatose for one-third
of the rotation of their Planet like
what's up with that they would be
completely stupefied by it just with and
we take it all for granted right so so
tell me what what's it doing for us
it turns out it's doing a lot right so
it's not just restoring things in your
brain so one of the most important
functions of sleep is uh basically
cleaning up debris through the What's
called the glymphatic system so Matthew
Walker uses this analogy of picture your
brain as Manhattan where the streets
represent the area between cells and at
night the street sweepers are coming out
and getting the trash out of those areas
it's also a time when you consolidate
memory right you can't consolidate
memory or new skill absent sleep it's
also a time when some of the most
important hormones in your body are
being synthesized or at least the
signals that tell those hormones to be
made so for example testosterone while
it's not made in the brain is made in
response to something called follicular
stimulating hormone or follicle
stimulating hormone and luteinizing
hormone those are maximally produced at
night as is growth hormone and things
like that but it also regulates very
important things which is easier and
sometimes there's things we don't fully
understand how it's doing it but we can
see experimentally when you even for a
short term deprive sleep you can induce
a horrible physiologic State and the
most obvious example it to me is that of
insulin resistance this is the precursor
to type 2 diabetes just a week of
significant sleep deprivation taking
normal healthy people and restricting
them down to four and a half hours per
night will induce a state of profound
insulin resistance in in about a week so
you get the sense even without fully
understanding mechanistically how this
is happening that disruptions of sleep
lead to horrible consequences both above
and below the neck with shift workers
you work those awfully unsocial hours
that must be a phenomenal risk of having
all sorts of problems with the sleep
that provides well let's say sleep
during the day
your body's programmed to do it at a
certain time of the day and all of a
sudden you're turning that on its head
yeah it's very difficult and it shifts
workers the question is can you change
your circadian rhythm is that possible
you can but it requires a lot of
manipulation of light so one of the
there's three basic driving forces for
Sleep one is cortisol one is light and
one is adenosine so we could talk about
all of them but let's just talk about
the light one the light one is sensed
through something called a pineal gland
right behind the eyes and so all that
gland is basically trying to ascertain
is when is it getting dark enough that I
can start secreting melatonin which is a
pro-sleep hormone so one of the
challenges that a shift worker is going
to have if they're not paying attention
to it is how do I make sure when I sleep
I create enough of a Darkness
environment that I get that hormone to
be produced to shift my physiologic
state and by the way that means that
they need light when they're working and
it has to be kind of the right kind of
light and unfortunately there's no
perfect substitute for sunlight
well and once again doctor I know you
went to med school and everything
um but the penile gland is much lower in
the body
anyway
um
shark has his own medical school
of medicine
and it exists below the device line as
well we're gonna take a quick break but
when we return for our third and final
segment we're gonna get deeper into sort
of our neurological health emotional
health other dimensions of what we will
care about as we get older here on
StarTalk
we're back on Star Fox sports edition
completely devoted to longevity and
we've got in-house as our expert Dr
Peter attia and he is host of the
podcast the drive and uh he's he he's
got a book out and again tell us about
your book Peter uh it's called outlive
the science and art of longevity yeah I
love that title all right so Gary keep
us going here what's next up all right
so what have you tied up we kind of
touched on in segment one the full
Horsemen of disease you know at least
things that
fight us in our aging battle so I
thought maybe we'd kind of try and
saddle one up and ride it a little bit
harder and find out a bit more and that
would be neuro degenerative disease
because I think as we get older a lot of
people's biggest fear is you know what
is my head going to be really good or am
I going to lose the plot what's going on
so there has to be a way because once
you get to that Alzheimer's and I sadly
lost my father to to dementia once it
gets to a certain point this trend only
goes in One Direction but is there is
there a way in the future we can
successfully battle something like this
or prevent it yeah exactly well I think
that's that's again the important
distinction and I'll be honest with you
I'm far more optimistic in our capacity
to prevent or at a minimum significantly
delay the onset of Alzheimer's disease
than I am in our capacity to treat it
once it takes hold
um and part of the problem is just that
protein folding is a really common
problem so the easiest example and
admittedly this is an oversimplification
is why does an egg change color when you
cook it like why does the white part of
the egg I think that's one of the most
fascinating things in the kitchen
between you and me I just say here's a
transparent fluid and a bada bing turns
white and exposed to heat it's like we
should Marvel at that more often than we
do I think and so here's the equally
remarkable thing Neil which is why can
we never go back from white to clear
because because eggs are racist
it's that simple
Chucky Chuck has made progress in his
race therapy but still occasionally
things like that slip out yeah okay so
so basically like there's a real problem
with folding and unfolding proteins and
once you move in that direction where so
the main protein of course like is you
have albumin and things like that inside
the egg protein once you apply heat
you're basically changing the shape of
the protein and it fails to be
translucent anymore and something very
similar is kind of happening in the
brain right which is as the amyloid beta
plaques and the neurofibrillary tangles
are wreaking havoc in the neurons
it does not appear to be reversible any
more than it appears reversible to take
a white egg and return it back to a
clear egg so
I think that if we're going to see
successful pharmacotherapy it's going to
have to be applied very early and that's
why I think today what's exciting is the
development of biomarkers that are being
applied to high-risk individuals before
they have symptoms but identifying the
seeds of problems so let's use an
analogy in cardiovascular disease I
don't want to wait until you're having
chest pain or God forbid a heart attack
to intervene interfere with drugs that
lower cholesterol instead what I'd
rather do is say look I can measure your
cholesterol and I know it's high and I
know what that's going to do and if I
really need to convince myself I could
look at a CT scan of your coronary
arteries and realize that oh by the way
you're already accumulating soft plaque
so similarly how do you know if someone
is susceptible to alzheimer's if they
don't yet have symptoms I think the two
most important ways are family history
so that's a that's a big predictor and
then the second genetics yeah and then
second is genetics so uh there's a
there's there's the same thing that's
the same thing right I mean not
necessarily not necessarily because
there are many people who get this that
are not getting it through the gene that
we are most commonly measuring so so so
the the gene I'm referring to is called
apoe so April lipoprotein e is the Gene
and this is an unusual Gene in that it
has three isoforms so most genes just
exist in one form so for example the LPA
gene or the APO B Gene there's just one
we all have the same one the the apoe
gene used to only exist in an isoform
called E4 that was the one that we
historically had for thousands of years
and about 200 000 years ago another one
showed up called the APO E3 isoform and
then about 25 000 years ago the APO E2
one showed up
what were the cavemen doing to make this
happen whatever whatever they were doing
they were like we got to forget this
mess well it's interesting here's a
great example of going back to what we
talked about earlier right the APO E4
Gene which is the one that our ancestors
had forever is the high risk Alzheimer's
Gene uh oh okay it served a very
important purpose which is it probably
helped us against infectious diseases
gotcha so it was probably a very good
Gene to have when you were young
especially for most of human history
when you were much more likely to die
from infectious diseases
but it turns out to not be as good a
gene to have given that you don't need
help with your genes to fight infectious
diseases anymore we have so many other
Technologies what we need is help not
getting Alzheimer's disease so 25 like
sickle cell and malaria that's exactly
right yeah the Sickle Cell will kill you
but the it keeps you alive long enough
to not get malaria right and so these
interesting biological trade-offs in our
life expectancy historically and it's a
little bit different right because
sickle cell is uh if you have you have
to have two copies of the gene to have
the phenotype and that would be negative
under any circumstance it's if you have
one copy of the gene there it is that of
course you're protected from malaria and
you don't have the phenotype and that
probably explains why that trait has
stuck around forever to a disease that
kills people Young when you say two
copies just for clarification you mean
that both people have to pass the same
gene at the same time to the to the
recipient is that that's in the case of
sickle cell you get you get one for each
parent one from each parent but but one
thing to keep in mind is the apoe4 gene
is quite different in the sense that
there's no evolutionary pressure to get
rid of that Gene because it doesn't
interfere with reproductive Fitness at
all right so this Gene is here to stay
you know absent like you know sci-fi
crispr stuff where we just get rid of it
but the point is people who have that
Gene depending on if they have one or
two copies are at an increased risk for
Alzheimer's disease so if you have one
copy of the apoe4 Gene and one copy of
either two or three your risk is about
two-fold higher Delta we've exercised
our bodies right for this the aim of
longevity now if someone and their blood
work presents with markers that you
think might be predisposed towards
dementia Alzheimer's do we then not
engage in some sort of cognitive skill
exercise that is working for our minds
as much as we do to exercise correctly
for our bodies absolutely but so is the
brain a muscle in this regard yeah not
not exactly the same but there is an
analogy but first of all exercise is
still the most important intervention we
have for brain health as well so uh that
shouldn't be forgotten so the exercise
you're doing for your body is also for
your brain both in terms of reducing
inflammation increasing growth factors
such as brain derived neurotropic Factor
bdnf
um increasing cardiovascular fitness
which in turn increases vascular Fitness
remember a lot of dementia is
exacerbated by microvascular disease
anything that deprives so just take a
step back the brain is like two percent
of your body weight and 25 percent of
your metabolic demand
yeah just kind of reflect on that for a
moment so anything that compromises any
bit of its metabolic Fitness is
disastrous
and that's why small vessel disease type
2 diabetes anything that compromises
that aspect of the brain is is is is
devastating with respect to dementia and
so exercise helps your phrase it's 25 of
our metabolic demand what you mean is of
all your calorie intake your body is
using one-fourth your brain is taking
one-fourth of it and the rest goes to
the rest of your body that's right and
despite it only when some of our some
some of our brains are doing
despite it being only two percent of
your body weight yeah I know some people
that is their brain is two percent of
their body weight and it's probably only
doing about two percent of the metabolic
to me
so to your question Gary then let's talk
about where brain games fit into this
right so the available evidence suggests
that brain games a commercial for Chuck
who hosts on the road because it was
still on the nose when he said let's
figure out the brain case with it I'll
tell you where it fits in uh you can
watch it on that Geo uh the card on
Disney plus where Chuck Nice is the host
Chuck Nice who's the host brain games on
the road okay there's a there's a
unanticipated commercial for Chuck okay
so continue Peter so it turns out that
cognitive Reserve is just as important
to the brain as physical Reserve is to
the body and what we call movement
Reserve so if you take 10 people and you
line them up in the order of their
physical or movement capacity so you got
one person who just kind of sits down
all day and does nothing and at the
other end of the spectrum you've got the
most sophisticated Ballroom dancer of
all time who can spin and flip and do
all sorts of things you you can
basically assume that they're going to
have that relationship towards their
ability to mitigate movement disorders
such as Parkinson's disease in other
words the more movement reserved you
have the the longer you can tolerate the
insult of the neurodegeneration before
you start showing symptoms and the same
is true with dementia so the higher your
cognitive reserve the longer you go
before you will experience symptoms and
so the question is what type of brain
activities boost cognitive reserve and I
think contrary to what people had hoped
it's not playing you know do it doing
you know sudoka or playing you know
crossword puzzles or things like that
like those things are very narrow in
what they're doing for your brain and
they tend to just make you better at
those things
whereas doing something very complicated
doing you know doing much more
cognitively complicated tasks like
learning a new language or yeah learning
a new language play the guitar or
something exactly doing things that have
many more moving pieces and requires
much more of the brain those do tend to
boost cognitive reserve and therefore
give us some protection against
cognitive decline how about learning a
musical instrument
I I think it seems that that's probably
in the take but once you get pretty good
it's easier I think for people to kind
of tone down the learning it so a lot of
it also has to do with how deliberate a
person is and how much they think about
so one of my hobbies is driving a race
car and you know for me that's
cognitively insanely challenging okay
yeah and it would have to be all right
doc so if we helicopter because you know
you are so close to this you know it's
right there in front of your face so if
we helicopter out
do we find all of these things are
somehow interconnected and independent
and dependent interdependent on each
other for a success in terms of it's
okay for me my body's good you know I'm
20 years younger than my actual sell-by
date uh but my brain's not there so I
need to do and is it all connected or
did they just sit separately
if you're referring to the interventions
that we do whether it be exercise sleep
Stress Management I think they are all
connected and you know give you an
example right if you're if you're doing
everything wonderfully through if you're
if you're following like say Peter
attia's prescription on exercise but
you're sleeping four hours a night and
you're checking your email all night and
living on social media getting bothered
by it yeah it's actually going to impair
your capacity to reap the benefits of
that domain yeah so it's it's better to
be kind of a seven out of 10 on
everything than a 10 out of 10 on one of
them and then zero out of ten on another
oh interesting interesting well balanced
life well balanced diet well balanced
everything I'm a fan of moderation but
only in moderation me too personally my
swim team had t-shirts made for me one
day that said moderation is The Only
Thing Worth doing in moderation yeah
yeah exactly the one okay so the one
thing we haven't really touched stone is
nutrition I'll call it nutrition
um and then you you have a phrase a
nutritional biochemistry
which doesn't seem to be as much fun as
me saying eating and enjoying so what
are we saying here eat less I'd like to
slip in there just Peter to get your
fast reaction
um almost everyone I've ever met
who said they became a vegetarian and
never felt better
in their change over to become
vegetarian it included the onset of an
exercise regimen
look and I I'm intrigued by this because
I've I along with you only you know it's
from experiments I know just from my own
life
that I've never felt better than when I
exercised no matter what I eat no matter
how much the eating is secondary
tertiary to the value of the that the
exercise brings to my body so how many
people are misunderstanding what are the
forces driving on what how they feel
with exercise relative to their diet
yeah you're you've hit the nail on the
head Neil um most of the nutrition
research is so heavily flawed in its
epidemiology by these healthy user
biases and you so you're right so
there's no virtually no epidemiologic
study that wouldn't suggest that
vegetarians are healthier than meat
eating people however these studies are
simply incapable of correcting for the
fact that people who select a vegetarian
diet make many other changes first of
all you're selecting just a different
group of people there's no randomization
to make that happen but you're selecting
people who are then saying I'm so health
conscious that I'm willing to give up
this thing that's not easy to give up
right it's so ubiquitous and in exchange
you know or as a result of that rather
I'm going to do a lot of things that are
healthy I'm going to be more mindful of
my exercise my stress yes exactly it's a
life shift yeah yeah yeah so that that's
absolutely correct and by the way that
comes back to Gary's Point why do I want
to talk about nutritional biochemistry
because I never want to talk about diets
I can't stand talking about diets it
makes me sick and all I want to do is
just talk about
prote amino acids fatty acids
carbohydrates how do these things work
what does energy balance mean why does
it matter put that all together you end
up with a diet
yeah except I think that I think it
doesn't need to I mean the problem with
diets is it becomes it so look food is
already an emotional topic for everyone
it's probably one of the reasons why I
think these diets become so tribal
that's part of how we identify I think
yeah so instead I just want to say look
yeah you become in group out group
that's right yeah yeah because really a
diet is whatever you're putting in your
body that is your diet period you know
so so I see what you're saying is once
you divorce yourself from you know the
emotion from the social aspect of the
diet uh from what Neil just said the
in-group out group crap once you break
it down to just what now you can talk
about it in such a way where it is truly
just nutrition that's right yeah so
let's ask the question protein
carbohydrates and fats that's right yeah
that's right you know that's it and
alcohol alcohol is the fourth
macronutrient right so those are your
those are your four things yeah and
I'm not suggesting you consume much from
that group but we need to acknowledge
that there are some people who are
getting 25 of their calories from
alcohol you my friend are my favorite
doctor ever
all right on that happy note we actually
have hit that one at a time what we will
do is go out and buy Peter's book
outlive the science of longevity where
we will learn how to tackle and and
navigate all of the bad hands that are
dealt us in
for what it is to be human and to get
older Peter it's been a delight to have
you on this show thank you for having me
gentlemen
all right Chuck and Gary uh always good
to have you there thank you
all right Neil deGrasse Tyson here your
personal assistant has always been
engaged to keep looking up
[Music]